the March jobs report is out and it is
not good it shows seven hundred and one
thousand jobs were lost the unemployment
rate is at four point four percent
that's exactly right let's bring in
Stuart Varney host of Varney & Company
on the Fox Business Network Stuart
what's your reaction to this okay let me
repeat those numbers because they are
indeed pretty bad we lost seven hundred
and one thousand jobs in the month of
March and the unemployment rate went up
to four point four percent now that's
bad but it doesn't really paint a true
picture of the employment market as we
speak
this survey week for the March at jobs
report was early in the month of March
so it didn't really capture the full
impact of the virus on our economy so
you can expect later in April these
jobless numbers will go way up perhaps a
better indicator of the true state of
employment is the fact that ten million
people applied for jobless benefits just
in the last two weeks and I might add
that Maria was just told by a Fed
governor Maria Bartiromo on Fox Business
that the unemployment rate now is
actually closer to ten percent already
and by the way we've got a big
investment firm morgan stanley
suggesting that the economy which we now
and June will shrink by thirty eight
percent now that is dire indeed you know
Stuart what is what is dire as well is
when the next number comes out keep in
mind when the president ordered people
to stay at home currently there are and
various governors have as well currently
there are stay-at-home orders in states
that account for eighty two percent of
our GDP if you've got eighty two percent
of the GDP people not going to work
that's gonna be ugly oh you can see this
I mean we've got a TSA checkpoints at
airports let two million fewer passenger
are being processed everyday than one
year ago the flights that take off for
essentially empty ridership on public
transportation is down 75% because if
people are not going to work they're not
commuting traffic is even eased up
throughout California that's
extraordinary all across the country
you've stopped people going to work so
the economy is at a dead stop and as
Morgan Stanley suggests it's actually
shrinking we've never seen anything like
this before
and we won't get over it until such time
as those matters stay at home orders
begin to be relaxed at that point you
might see things improve but not until
then all right so Stewart in 2008 these
numbers were intriguing because we want
to find out how the banking system was
gonna repair itself how many people are
affected and how to fix it with tarp now
these are not intriguing this is a
self-inflicted wound it's a slow-motion
car wreck that we brought on ourselves
because we've been told this is the only
way to do it
we should reverse it we should talk
about how many people are working
because the number is going to get
terrible this is only going to do this
is only going to reinforce what was
demanded by our government in the world
body that we stopped working stop
talking each other
stop being productive stop going to gyms
stop going out to dinner so to me I'm
even surprised I'd rather find out the
20% that are still on their jobs how
lucky we are to be doing this weird
weird anomaly now well look that makes a
fair point Brian but you can't sugarcoat
exactly where we are the government has
ordered a shutdown of the economy on
medical grounds and there'll be an
enormous political battle when we start
to see that curve bending in the right
direction when that happens there will
be a political battle as to how soon we
relaxed these stay at home orders
that'll be a monumental battle because
people who care about the economy and
the damage being done to the economy
will want to open it up again as soon as
possible on the other side you can have
people who say look you open up the
economy you open up the stay-at-home
rules too soon
you have a second way that the virus go
through with even more damage there's a
political battle coming and it's based
on the state of the economy which at
this point Brian is dire flat out on its
back dire situation Stuart we look at
that number yeah it's bad but does that
include the people in the restaurant
industry let's say who were laid off but
they're gonna get their jobs back and
through the stimulus money the
restaurant owners are not gonna have to
pay that money it's coming from the
federal government ok let's be clear the
money that's starting to go out today
there's 2.2 trillion dollars that is not
stimulus that is rescue that's money
going to the people who've been laid off
or out of work through no fault of their
own
it's money going to their paychecks it's
called the Paycheck protection thing and
small businesses can go to their banks
as of today and get a loan which
transfers it to a grant if they don't
lay people off so the money is being
pushed out there now but don't get don't
get the idea that somehow or other this
stimulates the economy it doesn't it
rescues a millions of individuals the
stimulus comes later when we start to
relax the stay at home rules and the
economy can expand that's when you need
the stimulus that's when it kicks in
that's right I like the way that you put
it that it is a rescue package for to
rescue the businesses and for all the
Americans Stuart as well who are simply
doing what dr. pouchy told us in about
35 minutes ago and that is the only way
at this stage before there is a vaccine
and we were uncertain about treatments
the only way to turn that corner on this
deadly thing is to stay at home and
that's why governors and the federal
government have mobilized to not only
order people to stay in place but also
they've got this rescue bill and today
is a day that small businesses
officially can start applying and as
provided they keep the people on the
books which is going to help the people
who they have furloughed they may not
have to they will not have to repay
those loans
that's true they become a grant if you
take this government money and you don't
lay people off if you do that you don't
lay people off then it's not a loan
which has to be repaid it's a grant
which doesn't have to be repaid is
enormous amount of money going out here
I think it's three hundred and seventy
seven billion dollars and Treasury
secretary minuchin says look if we run
out of that 377 billion will go back to
Congress we'll get some more it's a
rescue operation and it starts today
mister really quickly that number we see
at the bottom of the screen does that
include the people that were laid off
that will come back to work once once
this is all over
you mean the 700 and 1,000 the
unemployed we don't know that
I suspect that jobs back I don't know
but the only way to use that grant money
is if you give them their jobs back
so all those small businesses they're
gonna have to pay those loans back if
they don't rehire so of course they're
gonna rehire you look there is some
confusion here there there is some
confusion here you're a small business
operator you're in deep trouble you go
to the bank today and you say look
here's my payroll for the last eight
weeks they will give you that money as a
grant if you don't lay people off
they'll give it to you as a loan if you
do lay people off and you've got to
repay that loan so let's not get any
confusion here I don't know who's
included in which number but the rescue
operation starts today and it's a big
operation there might be another thanks
to advanced all noon Stuart Varney
meanwhile coming up in there